we believe the very Malibu dance there
is talk that they're renting an ocean
facing Villa
but even that California sunshine isn't
enough to keep Harry from feeling
homesick a source tells ET that Harry is
feeling very far from home at the moment
the 35 year old royal relocated to LA
with wife Megan Markel and their 11
month-old son Archie amid the corona
virus pandemic and the source adds that
it hasn't helped that they're on
lockdown in a place he doesn't know
according to the source Harry is feeling
cutoff and the time difference makes it
difficult for him to speak with his
family in the UK I hope that helps you
understand what did it come to but I
would step my family back from all I
have ever known
just take us to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
Harry and Megan officially said goodbye
to royal life on March 31st this has
come as a shock to the whole family but
although tensions were high amongst the
Royals at times during the Sussex 'iz
transition our source says that Harry
has been in regular touch with his
brother Prince William and sister-in-law
Kate Middleton his father Prince Charles
and his grandmother Queen Elizabeth
earlier this week Harry's good friend
dr. jane goodall claimed in an interview
with the Radio Times that the 35 year
old has been having a tough time telling
the outlet quote I don't know how his
career is going to map out but yes I've
been in touch though I think he's
finding life a little bit challenging
just now it doesn't help that his father
the Prince of Wales tested positive for
Kovan 19 last month though thankfully
he's now in good health I find myself on
the other side still in no nested stage
of social distance and general isolation
meanwhile Harry and Megan are doing
their part to give back during the
pandemic each II can confirm that the
Sussex is donated more than a hundred
and twelve thousand dollars to the UK
charity feeding Britain which works to
eliminate hunger in the country Megan
and Harry used money generated from
their royal wedding broadcast according
to a statement from their spokesperson
to ET the Duke and Duchess are delighted
to be able to ensure this money is
donated to such a great cause what's
more ET has also learned that over
Easter weekend
Harry video chatted with families caring
for seriously ill children at home with
the help of well child
Harry learned about the challenges and
fears these families are faced with
during the pandemic and offered this
message of hope for respects to every
single one of you because this is hard
on everyone but it is especially hard on
you keep going keep the morale up keep
yourselves busy in creative keep doing
new things there yourselves to do new
hobbies and yeah I hope to see you all
again very soon
[Music]